hello everyone you already seen two
games on my channel between Murphy and
Henderson and while one was the casual
game they played one was from their
official match in 1858 Murphy won both
of those games but just so we don't
think that more if you want all the
games
Anderson did win two games from their
match and this is a game from round
number ten this is well won one round
after the game from the previous video
that game more if you want in the
Sicilian defense and well Anderson
decided to change the approach to this
match although it was pretty much too
late he was already lost but he wanted
to give Murphy a real taste of the
German mastery and he decided to play
one two one two a three on the first
move
so not really going for any tactical
melees against more feet this time we
had a five c4 Knight to f6 Knight to c3
and the d5c captures on d5 Knight
captures on d5 and III so it's it's like
mr. Anderson decided to play the
Sicilian but only with the white pieces
with the colors reversed and with this
extra move of the pawn so Bishop takes
Bishop to e6 Knight to f3 and Bishop to
d6 and Bishop to e2 preparing to castle
morphic castles anderson castles and we
have Knight captures on c3 be captures
on c3
f5 and E for more if he pushes efore and
we have a knight to be to kind of
locking Anderson's pieces in but to this
wall be fixed very soon rook the six
more feet does a rook lift preparing for
rook to g6 or h6 well depending on what
anderson place and anderson goes for f4
now closing this dark square Bishop
Bishop of Morpheus on d6 and well
although morphe would like this bishop
to be free playing a move like a
captures on f3 I wouldn't really be that
good for black for example Knight
captures an f3 and now all of Anderson
pieces are completely free to develop he
can play Queen c2 Bishop d3 pushy 4 and
what this is
played played by itself
so after f4 more if you decided to go
for rock to h6 preparing Queen to h4
going for King side attack g3 Anderson
stops this we have Knight to d7 and
Knight to c4 not really play planning to
grab this Bishop on d6 as it's not
really doing anything
the idea is nice to e5 placing the
Nightstalker a nice central square so
instead of allowing this a morphe
decided to trade in his light square
bishop for the knight the bishop
captures on c4 Bishop captures and c4
now with check and we have king to a
chase rope to a to understand does a
mini ROK lift to protect his pawn and h2
from any future attacks by morphe Queen
to e7 preparing to bring the other rook
into the game now a four we have a
Knight to f6 Queen to b3 attacking the
b7 pawn now c6 and Bishop to e6 now well
it so it's pretty annoying Bishop there
I'll give mr. Anderson debt but rook to
e8 and Murphy forces the bishop to go
back so Bishop to c4 and Knight to g4
Morpheus well really trying to make
something happen here but it's really
hard the Queen can't really get get
anywhere in there if maybe if the rook
wasn't any age then maybe Queen to e8
and Queen to h5 would be possible but
this rockin a2 is doing a pretty good
job protecting the second rank so root 2
G 2 by Anderson we have rook to b8 now
preparing to push the b-pawn Bishop to
Bishop to e2 now attacking the knight
and I goes back to f6 and we have c4 b6
buy more feet Bishop to b2 now lining up
the bishop to this very strong diagonal
as the king is on h8 Queen to f7
we have Queen to c2 as well
now while the Queen is here you can't
really push c5 as the Queen would be
hanging here
so after Queen to c2 we have Bishop to
e7
now Bishop to c3
look back the g8 and we have a five and
or someone's to break this kingside a
queen set pawn majority morphe has here
Bishop to d6 now a capture some b68
capture some b6 and now rook to a one
Anderson wins this very nice a file for
his rook and well this is well kind of
the critical position of the game as the
position is about equal and there's any
script controlling a bit more space and
the would move like for example roof to
see it or rook to b8 this would well
still be anyone's game
but morphe probably got tired of
dispositional piece pushing and he
decided to go for the attack and play g5
and it's a very bold move but well
you're really opening your King up to
this bishop on c3 after a move like c5
or d5 is played this will be very hard
to hold for more fee F captors and g5 by
Anderson rook captures on g5 and we have
rook - aah check Anderson plays this
rook to e8 check actually with the idea
of exchanging Queens not allowing more
feet to create any sort of an attack
rook the g8 rook sorry Queen to a 4
now protecting the rook and a8 and also
attacking the c6 pawn rook captures an
a8 Queen captures an a8 would check and
also with an attack on c6 pawn and the
Morphy has to play Queen to e8 now
defending check and also protecting the
c6 pawn and under some exchanges Queen's
Queen captures Knight captures and now
c5 and this was pretty much the entire
idea that reviewed as Morpheus g5 move
the forcing of the exchange forcing the
exchange of Queens and after that
happened this c5 move as now morphe
cannot capture this pawn if she captures
then D captures on c5
opening up a discovered check and the
winning this Bishop on d6
so after c5 Bishop to c7 was played and
now Bishop to c4 again now not allowing
the King to escape through g8 and again
the thread of the d5 is still here so
more free play is king to g7 we have C
captures on b6
captures mb6 and now rook the b2 Bishop
to c7 and now rook the b7 pinning the
bishop so a very hard position for black
to play as this bishop pair anderson has
is well extremely powerful King to f6
we have Bishop to b4 although d5 here
was completely winning for for white as
well but Anderson decides to do it the
other way and Bishop to b4 rook the rook
to g6 and now Bishop to f8 h v King to
f2 h 4g captures on h4 now rook to g4 h5
rock to h4 and now h6 the whole point of
the bishop to f8 move and now protecting
this h6 bounine it's a very dangerous
passed pawn rook captures on h2
King to g1 rock to h3 now attacking the
e3 pawn bishop to f1 with an attack on
the roof rook checks a king to f2 and
well why not why not capture the pawn
for example if rook captures pawn on e3
what what does mr. Anderson play well h7
and there is no way to stop white from
from h8 Queen so after Bishop to f1 rock
to g3 check King King to f2 and now rook
to g4 now an 8 7 isn't that deadly
because the rook can go to h4 so Bishop
to c4 rook to h4 and now Bishop the g8
preparing h7 Bishop to d6 offering an
exchange of bishops and mr. Anderson
happily obliges Bishop captures and d6
night captors on d6 and now rook to d7
with an attack on the night night Stewie
8 and now h7 a very very dangerous pawn
already King to g5 Murphy has to find
some counter play rook to e7 night to
thief Knight to d6 rook the e6 again
with an attack on the knight Knight the
c4
rook captures in c6 Knight study to
kingi to attacking the knight and now
rook to h2 with check at King be one now
Knight to f3 rook to c7 King has to go
to g6 Anderson pushes d5 we have f4 e
captures on f4 and now III Morpheus
preparing to push e - we have rook to e7
but now of course again upon to e2 with
chick rook captures and now rook to h1
this was more of his idea as now rook to
e1 is impossible and the King has to go
to c2 so King c2 and now Knight d4
checking the king and also forking the
rook king due to Knight captures rook
King captures night and we have g7 by
Morphy preventing h8 Queen so morph is
root canal move and okay Morpheus up the
exchange but Anderson has the three
pawns and this is too much
King III we have a rocky one checking
before rook F one attacking the pawn
king if I've depending again rook e1
check King f5 the rugby one now Bishop
to e6 rogue before a king e5 with tempo
rogue d1 now f5 rook h 1f sex with check
King captures this pawn was happily
sacrificed King to d6 now rock day one
King 287 an hour up to a 7 1 less check
by Murphy and now Bishop to d7 and in
this position mr. Murphy resigned the
game as there is no defense against f7
and f8 Queen this is just too much so
yeah that's the game I do hope you
enjoyed it and well in the end they
played 11 games
the result was seven wins four more feet
two wins for mr. Anderson and two of the
games were drawn so a very nice showing
by mr. Murphy but Anderson well thought
that even even if it's the end of the
match that he should give more fee one
more game like
this even though it took 77 moves he
showed him the positional style of
German mastery so yeah that's the game I
do hope you enjoyed it as usual you can
check to my previous videos here this is
all these are all of the games i'm going
to show from the match morphe understand
of 1858 but i will put a link in the
description below where you can check
out all of the games if you would like
so yeah that's it thank all for watching
and I will see you soon